[Music]
hi everyone i'm working on a procedural
modular terrain system for my projects
in unity
when i say projects of course i mean
games but i'm a behavioral scientist so
i wanted something that would work for
behavior simulations too
in unity you can simulate all sorts of
things like boys
utility ai
neural networks and kinesis
keep an eye out on my channel for more
of this kind of thing and let me know in
the comments what kind of simulations
you think would be fun
in the past i spent a lot of time
working on procedural voxel terrain i've
done minecraft style boxes marching
cubes
and dual contouring
there were challenges
sometimes they were interesting like
this was one of my first attempts at
marching cubes to rain no idea what
happened here
looks kind of neat though other times
well okay i know i know what it looks
like i promise i promise it's not what i
was going for
i knew i wanted to move away from the
kind of voxel complexity i've spent far
too much time on
and then i learned about wave function
collapse
no not this wave function collapse
this wave function collapsed hey don't
get mad at me i didn't name it so this
method can generate 2d textures from
input or generate 3d worlds from modules
the texture version looks something like
this
you saw the 3d version at the beginning
of the video
let me tell you how i got here
i was starting a new side project
as one often does and at the time i was
really into pixel art and classic
top-down games like legend of zelda i
like the fun little perspective tricks
they use like look at how the walls are
angled to get better visibility
they even angle the models in some of
the top down 3d games
i wanted to make a 3d procedural mesh
that had the same top-down pixel art
vibe and angled walls and i did
and i like the overall look at the first
attempt
it helps that i'm borrowing a lot from
textures like castlevania zelda and
metroid i'm also using a pixel art
shader on the characters while i was
working on this i got really distracted
by a heart style and maybe i'll talk
about that in another video
my next task was to remove gaps between
adjacent blocks at first i tried a
custom extruded version of marching
squares and it worked really well until
it didn't then i tried marching cubes
remember how i said i didn't want to use
voxels
well here i am again using voxels it did
exactly what i wanted but it was so much
work
let me tell you a little bit about
marching cubes and you can see where i
went wrong
here i have a 3d grid of voxels
the dark voxels represent solid material
while the light voxels represent open
space
you can kind of imagine what the overall
shape will be
especially if i don't show the open
voxels
they're still there they're just not
being shown
you might be tempted to place a cube
everywhere there's a solid voxel
this is the voxel approach used by
minecraft
it's nice but you can really only get
cubic shapes
the marching cubes method uses a cell of
eight voxels
one in each corner remember the open
voxels are still there too
a mesh is built inside the cell to
separate the solid and open voxels here
a flat ground mesh is created since
there are four voxels at the bottom of
the cell
in the next cell an angled ramp is
needed to cover the solid voxels
this cell has all solid voxels so it's
completely underground and doesn't need
a mesh
now we create another flat ground mesh
to cover the four bottom voxels
and this process continues as the cell
marches through the voxel grid rating a
mesh anywhere one is needed
that's the basic process of marching
cubes
there are a lot of ways to build the
individual cell meshes but generally
there are 256
possible meshes that could be built
normally do the smart thing and find
some pre-calculated marching cubes mesh
tables online to help out but i'm not
always that smart
i coded all of this manually and i
didn't even get to use my old marching
cubes code
it was a lot of work and i don't
recommend this at all i even have way
more than 256 cases for all these
special rules i just wanted more control
over the types of shapes that i could
get than the standard marching cubes
rules would provide
i wanted both blocky shapes and beveled
shapes
eventually with my version of the
algorithm i was able to get pretty much
what i wanted
but i still didn't like it it was weeks
of work and i regret all of it
i just didn't like it what really got me
was the texturing i was trying a lot of
different styles but texturing is one
area where voxel algorithms are weak
since the mesh is built procedurally you
have much less artistic control than if
you built and textured a mesh in the 3d
modeling program so looking back at this
it's not all bad
but i just didn't like it it wasn't
really what i wanted and i was
frustrated
but i did find an interesting solution
i was looking at twitter and you can
follow me there too
and i saw a post from oscar stallberg
the creator of bad north and townscaper
he was sharing a devlog from the
creators of phantom brigade where they
discussed their procedural terrain
system
so first check out this game i've played
some other games but not this one does
look really cool though they used a
modular system for their buildings that
i really like
here's their post on modular buildings
link in the description they create 3d
tiles based on marching cube's rules and
assemble them using a modified marching
cubes algorithm
but because they create the meshes by
hand in a 3d modeling program they have
full artistic control of the shapes and
materials they use and it really works
great
i really like the idea of making 3d
tiles instead of using the standard
marching cube shapes but i also didn't
want to be restricted by marching cube's
rules at all i dug a little deeper and i
started reading more of oscar
stahlberg's posts he uses a method
called wave function collapse yes we
finally get to it
in oscar stahlberg's bad north wave
function collapse is used to generate
these cute little islands they look
great and more importantly they don't
look anything like you would get from
marching cubes
in townscaper you build these little
towns that's it
everything's assembled with wave
function collapse and it looks nothing
like marching cubes
it's fun and super cheap so check it out
here's how wave function collapse works
first to create modules
here i have a simple 2d grass tile
the grass tile connects to the little
trees tile and vice versa i'm creating
matches for each tile based on adjacency
the big trees tile connects to the
little trees tile but not to grass
sand connects to grass but not to trees
and finally water connects to sand let's
also assume that every tile can connect
to itself
now that the modules are ready we need a
grid of cells
initially each cell can contain any of
the modules we can say that the domain
of each cell initially includes all
possible modules now we pick a random
cell
and randomly assign a module
the cell has now been collapsed we also
know how to reduce the domains of the
neighboring cells we know that the
little trees module can only be placed
near other little trees big trees and
grass
reducing the domains of the neighboring
cells might also reduce the domains of
the neighbor's neighbors when we
collapse one cell we need to propagate
the information to all cells that should
change
now we pick a new cell to collapse
it should probably be a cell with a
small domain
each time we collapse the cell we
propagate the new constraints to
adjacent cells
watch how the domain sizes decrease each
time we collapse a new cell
i'll let this play out a bit so you can
see the process
[Music]
and i'll also speed it up a bit too
[Music]
and that's it that's way function
collapse
[Music]
here's the same tile set on a much
bigger map
the process is nearly instant when it
isn't being animated but i also really
like watching the algorithm work
one of the nice things about this method
is that you can set whatever
connectivity rules you want
and the algorithm will figure out how to
put things together
for the most part
okay so that was a simple set of tiles
for this demonstration
here's a more serious set of pixel art
tiles
i was really into pixel art for a bit
while i was working on this
i'm not great at it but it's a style i'd
like to get better at
the little worn down pathways in this
one are kind of interesting
and i like how the flowers turned out
i have some rules here that clump the
flowers and weeds together but don't
group those with the trees
it's all about setting rules for how the
tiles can connect
you have a lot of creative freedom
here are some 3d sets i've been working
with
the algorithm works pretty much the same
in 3d
i'm following general marching cube's
design guidelines for creating my
modules but i can also ignore a lot of
it or add my own rules to
it's really nice to be unrestricted by
voxel meshing rules
for this one i was playing around with
small river and waterfall modules that
always flow south
that's the kind of thing you can't do
with marching cubes
[Music]
and here the trees might look a little
weird during generation but that's
because the tree mesh is randomly picked
from a few different options when the
mesh is built during animation the mesh
has built each update
randomly picking a mesh to use means i
can have one module that can have
multiple looks
would be much less performant to have
one module per tree type
okay that's about it for this video i
hope you enjoyed it
in the next video i'll go into technical
details about how wavefunction collapse
works and about how my own code
works please do all the normal youtube
things like subscribe hit the bell swipe
right tell your mom you love her reach
out to an old friend but also let me
know what you're thinking in the
comments it would be nice to talk to
people with similar interests
all right that's all for now see you
next time